[Music]
[Applause]
speaking of the NFL owners meetings Ben
volen covers the NF NFL for the Boston
Globe he's been covering the NFL since
2007. he's on a train back to Boston
from the NFL meetings front and center
for jimmers saves comments and Ben joins
us now Ben how would you sum up the uh
NFL owners meetings
boring and uh predictable until about
four in the afternoon when Jim irsay out
of nowhere just dropped a bombshell on
all of us and I was standing next to
Albert Greer in the media strum and we
just kept looking at each other like is
this really happening is he really
saying this because these owners they
never break ranks you never hear one
owner speaking ill of another they
always keep their issues in-house
everything is very carefully planned
they keep the media you know Behind
These velvet ropes and in like a pen
basically at these meetings and they
have Goodell and NFL people give press
conferences so they can let the owners
you know sneak out the side door like
everything is very carefully crafted so
for ursay to go kind of off the um Off
Script and to rip Daniel Snyder and to
say that yeah we probably need to vote
this guy out that was shocking and uh
that certainly made all of our stories
yesterday all right let me uh let people
in on what happened here's uh the
question to Jim irsay the Colts owner on
possibly having Dan Snyder's sell his
team you said that Dan Snyder should get
removed should the Snyder family sell I
said he should there's consideration
that he should be removed you know we
have to complete the investigation but
to me it's something that I think
serious consideration has to be given to
the removal and we have complete
authority to do that of him we'll just
support a family period I think uh in
general of him being removed and selling
the franchise
those are pretty strong words there and
you're right Ben this is the first time
I can ever remember something like this
happening where you know one owner turns
on another owner but
um I guess I'm curious what what is
what's Jim irsay doing here why why do
you think he broke ranks
50 years ago so he has grown up in the
NFL he's 62 years old now and for some
of these older families the rooneys the
ursays the maras the NFL is their
identity it just means more to them and
nurse they said the things that have
gone on uh in the Washington football
team for the last two decades are
reprehensible and and do not reflect the
values of the NFL and I think what irsay
said yesterday was 100 right I think the
surprising thing was just that
um he broke ranks and Roger Goodell
um he basically said
hey good he basically told the other
owners to zip it we don't need to be
talking
and that's as close as you'll ever hear
to Goodell admonishing one of his 32
bosses so I think NFL legal department
probably wasn't thrilled to see Earth
Day talking because that could
complicate things if and when Dan Snyder
ends up suing the league
um but I I think irsay is just really uh
you know had his to his wits end with
Snyder and all the bad news that he's
brought um to the NFL and by speaking
out yesterday I think he amps up the
pressure on the fellow owners to kind of
do the right thing and to ultimately
vote Dan Snyder out
but I don't know if the commissioner's
been asked this he said before in front
of Congress hey I don't have the power
to be able to do this I just want to ask
him what is the process to get started
here how does it start and could you
start it could Jimmer say have started
it yesterday uh that's why I don't know
if you have the answer to it but that's
what I would want to know from the
commissioner
so I think all it takes is 32 of the 32
men sitting around in a room and
deciding hey do we want to bring this to
a vote Jim Murphy I guess could have
brought it to a vote yesterday but uh
Roger Goodell I think smartly is
convinced the other 30 owners we don't
need to be taking any action here until
we get
um the report back from Mary Jo White
they want the facts they want the legal
document behind them as their Hammer
when they whenever they do decide so I
think all it takes is just at one of
these League meetings whether it's the
but how do you do that Ben if Daniel
Snyder is in the meeting and you go uh
hey uh new business yeah we'd like to
get rid of Dan Snyder all in favor say
hi
well I mean they've done it before where
they ask when they're talking about
someone they asked me to leave the room
so I know okay okay it would have to be
it would have to be Tanya Snyder his
wife who's representing him she would
have to leave the room and they'd have
to put you know everyone put your head
on your desk and thumbs up thumbs down
you know
uh you had a little uh get together with
Robert Kraft and Jerry Jones what what
was that about
so apparently Jerry is once again waging
a little bit of a battle against Roger
Goodell and his compensation I guess
Jerry just wants Roger to earn it as
opposed to just being handed big fat
stacks of money
um like I think most C CEO compensations
probably tied to bonuses and performance
and things of that nature and I guess uh
Robert Kraft didn't agree with him and I
don't think many owners did because I
believe Jared Jones uh his measure or
the the measure past 31-1 with Jerry
Jones the only one uh voting against but
Robert I guess told Jerry that he was
wrong and Jerry told Robert to shut the
bleep off and using very very colorful
language and that's uh a reporting from
ESPN Seth Wickersham who always does
such a tremendous job at these owners
meetings so
um I believe Robert crap that's it
excuse me because usually you don't hear
such forceful salty language directed at
billionaires before and I think Jerry I
think he cleaned up his language and
said well don't mess with me I think you
cleaned it up the second time realizing
he perhaps overstepped his boundaries so
never a dull moment when these
billionaires get together in a room
since you're headed back to Boston you
uh cover for the Boston Globe we're
talking to Ben volan senior NFL writer
you got some drama there going on with
the Patriots or at least it feels like
that with Mac Jones and Bill Belichick
and a relationship reportedly is
sideways uh what's next in this soap
opera
we do have a good old-fashioned
quarterback controversy it feels like
2001 all over again
um yeah it's going to be a tough
decision I think for Belichick this week
uh Monday night football against the
Bears Matt Jones probably a lot closer
to 100 I don't know if he's fully there
yet on that sprained ankle but the team
is playing so well with Bailey zappy uh
he's played three games and he's had a
hundred pass a rating in each game they
blow out wins over the lines and and the
Browns the last couple weeks so I I
personally I think
oh he was just about
yeah either keep it let him play his way
out of it and then go back to Mac Jones
but I don't necessarily run run the
Patriots and
you know oh Jones I think we have a bad
connection there Ben
oh no uh okay so do you think that I
don't know if there is Mac Jones making
this a tougher decision because of his
personality like Bailey's happy is
playing well but I don't know if Mac
Jones's role is making it worse for him
uh so you have me back now Dan yes all
right great uh so yeah there's there's
been a lot of smoke right now that just
since training camp that Matt Jones and
the coaching staff haven't always seen
eyes high that Mac was you know
wondering why
that everyone you know was very curious
about Matt Patricia and Joe judge two
guys who have never coached on the
offensive side of the ball never been
coordinators before
um that you know Mack was had lifted an
eyebrow is this the best setup for me
and then obviously the first few games
of the Season he really really didn't
play well and and threw a bunch of
interceptions and all of a sudden
Bailey's a happy comes in and he's a
rookie fourth round pick Mr yes sir no
sir and the team is playing really well
so there is you know some smoke right
now that uh uh Mac Jones and the
coaching staff haven't always seen eye
to eye
um and like I said I think we'll truly
see how Belichick feels about Mac Jones
I think this week because if if Matt
Jones is his guy and he loves his guy
then he's gonna play him against the
Bears but if there are some questions
about whether you know he could play on
the ankle and whether he's truly our our
set franchise quarterback then I think
they're probably going to go with zappy
again and that will only amp up I think
the quarterback controversy so whether
Mac plays this week I think will be very
telling about how Belichick feels about
it Ben thanks for joining us safe
travels back we appreciate your time
all right thanks a lot guys uh that's
Ben Bolin senior NFL writer of the
Boston Globe